previously on Peugeot stuck hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to pogo stuck I've calmed
down I've done some deep breathing I got
some water everything is fine and I'm
ready to try this again with a little
more sensibility in my head just because
I fail does not mean it's a does not
mean it's a bad thing
it's just what happens I really wish
there weren't other people here but
that's okay nothing I can do about it
that's the nature of the game it's
called rage with your friends which is a
really cool thing it's really nice that
they got this multiplayer aspect in here
cuz that kind of makes it you know new
and fresh it innovates on the concept
which I'm always a fan of so that's good
there we go so far so good
up and over yes okay bonk your head okay
here we go nope okay just like they did
just like they did easy-peasy just like
they did stop wiggling nope I get to try
God dear me that's not fair that's
heartbreaking why would you do that to
me oh come on I just wanted to try I've
tried one
what's in the entire time of doing this
section I've gotten to try and once oh
my god
I don't even know what I'm doing anymore
nothing that I'm doing makes any sense
Oh God nothing I just don't understand I
don't understand I don't I really don't
understand what the hell is wrong with
me oh god I should be so far past
second-guess oh my god
I just I'm done I'm done yammering I'm
done yammering I'm done
whining I just want to play the game god
I can't even get this first thing
anymore how is that possible that I I
I'm capable of like doing it so well the
first time I get in here and then it's
it's not just here it's every single
time I play a game that requires any
sort of skill is like I do totally fine
the first two or three passes I do
completely fine and then for some reason
everything I learned up until that point
goes out the window everything I know
goes out the window oh my god oh my god
I want to show you guys some progress I
really do I'm really trying guys I'm
really trying
I swear I'm really trying here I don't
know what happens to me like I know it's
it's something to do with my emotional
state I get that you armchair
psychologists I get it that makes sense
to me what I don't get is how even if
it's not a rage game that's how it
happens every time
I can be calm as a cucumber and it will
still happen oh my god how can I thread
that needle so tightly oh my god just I
don't care anymore
oh my god I don't understand I don't I
don't understand how I can be fine and
totally fine make so much progress the
very first time and then completely [ __ ]
everything up the only answer
or I'm an idiot or I'm doing it on
purpose and I swear to god I'm not an
idiot and I'm not doing it on purpose
I think some part of me is like
sabotaging myself that's the only
explanation is there some gremlin that
lives in my brain and decides to pull
strings at the wrong times here we go
here we go here we go this is it get my
head that's fine
stop don't don't know what okay well you
try some what second shot oh [ __ ] there
we go
I don't oh god that's the [ __ ] worst
I thought it couldn't get any worse okay
here we go here we go I'm just gonna
keep going oh god here we go here we go
here we go yes yes yes oh my god no no
no no no oh God
okay here we go that's fine oh that's
honey ah
[ __ ] me oh my god what the [ __ ] okay I'm
not gonna complain
cuz I'm here now oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh holy [ __ ]
no no no [ __ ] oh [ __ ] there I go oh here
I am it's fine okay
okay that's fine I wanted to go there
okay I've made it to here I don't know
what this means for me except Oh God
there I go oh no god damn it there I
[ __ ] go I don't understand what just
happened what happened can you just go
away okay I don't know what happened but
it was amazing
I made progress I feel really good I
feel good it feels so good when I make
progress it feels so good
ooh tingles is this what an someone
[ __ ] I hate you so much you're the
opposite of ASMR oh my God why would you
intend
choose that no if I didn't curve there
it would have been fun stop being an
[ __ ]
stop god [ __ ] oh my god I swear you
are the worst human ever in the history
of ever you're the worst human you are
the worst you must understand that you
must know why is that not superboost God
so much why would you do that to those
around you why why would you do that
Oh God ah [ __ ] it's really it's just
it's like nails on a chalkboard
there we go we're gonna keep oh god it's
not a booth why was that not a pose are
you kidding me oh my god why was that
not boosted okay really god dammit god
dammit god dammit I'm back in it to win
it
okay here we go here we go here we go
here we go get your head get your head
no no stop oh okay that's weird
no god oh why did I okay I ruin every
single opportunity that's put in front
of me I sabotage myself at every turn at
every single turn I sabotage myself
that's what I mean the little gremlin
that lives in my brain is sabotaging me
you're trying to make me feel like I'm
an idiot when in reality it is you that
is the idiot Gremmie
happening so adapt overcome overcome a
[ __ ]
oh no god damn it god damn you oh [ __ ]
off oh shut the [ __ ]
ah maybe I deserve all this maybe this
is my punishment for something I did I
don't know what I did but I feel like
this can only be a punishment so okay
every time that doesn't get boosted I'm
gonna gank out one of my ball hairs
that's what I'm gonna do I'm just gonna
let start a collection I'm gonna make a
sculpture of this Pogo guy out of my
pubes one god damn pube at a time okay
oh my god are you I got to stop asking
if they're kidding me
because it's very clear to me that they
are not kidding when they do the crap
that they're pulling there they're not
kidding like this game this came don't
kid around when it comes to that stuff
no why would you do that why would you
having a perfectly lovely time no God Oh
why god damn it I there's a science to
which death [ __ ] Christ there's a
science to which way you're supposed to
turn when you jump and like I've almost
got it down but I haven't quite
obviously got it down
god damn yo oh my god I am going to
strangle a bear I'm gonna strangle a
bear with my bare hands I will strangle
a goddamn grizzly bear I'm gonna rip out
its ball hairs add it to my ball hair
sculpture and then you know what I'm
gonna sell it on eBay oh my god could I
thread the needle any better could I do
it can I for that that gap is [ __ ] it
tiny and I hit it every time I am so
good at [ __ ] it up
I am the best that be
a royal [ __ ] if it is just the
narrowest gap and I hit it every [ __ ]
time every time it is it is um here I go
again yes please [ __ ] there we go
I hit it every [ __ ] time I hit it
every [ __ ] time I don't want to be
angry I don't want this I don't want I
don't like this I like the game
everybody stop
I like the guy I wouldn't be playing it
if there wasn't some visceral joy to be
had about this experience I like a
challenge
I don't like this game I like a
challenge and I don't give up I just
don't I'm not that type of person I
never quit I just don't know when to
quit like it's it's a strength and a
weakness but I don't quit but I just
don't want to be angry I don't like
being angry it's just such a painful
thing it's so painful
there we go here we are no stop and yes
here we go okay no God where am i okay
there I go
you know just [ __ ] forget it just
forget any hope of recovering anything
cuz it never works it never works look
at this look at me getting good okay oh
my god I had to open my big [ __ ]
flapper and there I go reading oh my god
no not again
[Music]
I don't get it I don't get it I don't
get it I don't [ __ ] get it how can I
in it every time I did it so perfect
every time it's not fair it's not fair
it's not fair it's not fair it's not
fair that I hit that every single time
it's not fair I hit it every goddamn
time how many times have I been trying
to climb this [ __ ] tree and every
time I fail it's because I hit it right
at the frickin edge of existence oh my
god I can't believe that that's so
unfathomably unfair it's so unbelievably
unfair it just is it's not fair stop no
I did it again
I don't okay here I go I can't see where
I am okay here we go No God so painful
it's so painful ah there go all my ball
hairs and there I go okay ha ha ha this
is fun as fun it's fun guys it's fun
what I'm doing here is what one would
call [ __ ] fun fun fun stop doing that
HAP no I can't how that's it's [ __ ]
impossible there's no way a human could
be that [ __ ] precise as me em with
hitting that gap there's no it's not
possible it should not be possible no no
no no god oh [ __ ]
- stop stop stop stop stop god i every
time i say here we go I somehow managed
to [ __ ] it up even more than I did
before no God I swear to God
I swear to [ __ ] and I'm ruining my
chances get back up God [ __ ] off [ __ ]
off you don't understand this why am i
failing is the only question I have in
my head cuz that's the only way that I
could get better is if I if I'm like
okay what what's going wrong how can i
how can I fix it what can I do to be
better and and it's like I don't know I
don't know what I could do to be better
I'm trying everything in my power to be
better and nothing's working I'm not
getting any better I'm not getting any
closer to the truth I I don't feel like
I'm making any progress
god damn it damn it oh no no no oh [ __ ]
here I go and I'm going back up for it
oh my god I made it oh [ __ ] off
anything I'm gonna be able to tell my
grandkids about how proud I was that I
got to the top of this mountain that I
got to the top of a knock off game of a
game that I hated that I actually spent
time and worked and strove real hard to
do this
tell us about the time that you beat
Pogo stuck well I'll tell you who's real
doozie but I got it
just you be bazinga Popeye I used to be
famous are the youtubes yeah grandpa
what's YouTube roar you kids suck I'm a
terrible man
no no God okay we're good we're good
we're good
hit that okay okay interesting and we're
back in it somehow oh my god oh my god
oh my god here we go work we're at we're
[ __ ] up we're back we're all oh [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] kidding me oh my god are
you kidding me please tell me I'm
dreaming and that was not actually what
happened oh my god okay well this'll be
easy right I've already done it
therefore I could do it a million times
in my soul no please not now
I'm sure Chuck oh that's all that's all
time I got for that episode thank you
everybody so much for watching oh oh boy
okay yeah thank you if you want more of
this so let me know whoa let me know
bring that bow just thank you God check
out more in the description as always -
see you next one bye bye
Oh
[Music]
you